it's been a long time
hey guys pete here just a little over
eight years ago the final episode of the
eighth season of dexter aired as a
series finale now the character's been
reborn in a limited series called dexter
new blood and this will be my breakdown
of the first episode it was a promising
reintroduction to the bay harbor butcher
whose circumstances have changed quite a
bit in a decade of hiding it's been 10
years of abstinence where he isn't
killing anyone not even people who would
be fair game according to the code
although we aren't sure how many of
those he might have encountered since
he's not actively looking for them he
may be on the straight and narrow in
that regard but he's still the same
character at his core and as you'd
imagine things get complicated we'll get
into all of that after a quick spoiler
warning if you haven't watched episode 1
yet then this video won't be for you and
with that out of the way let's get into
it new blood's first episode is titled
cold snap and most of the episode is
dedicated to introducing us to the new
setting the new characters and setting
the table for the upcoming season we
find dexter morgan in december 2021 he's
left miami he spent at least some time
up there in oregon where we last saw him
at the end of season 8. he's living in
the small town of iron lake new york and
has taken on the fake name jim lindsey
this is a nod to the dexter book series
author jeff lindsay he seems to have
settled into an unassuming small town
existence he works at a fish and game
store he's in what appears to be a
healthy relationship with the chief of
police he's got some land and some
livestock that he looks after and he's
got a routine that involves stalking an
albino buck in the woods near his cabin
and he does carry a rifle with him when
he does this but it doesn't seem like he
has any intention of killing the
majestic animal it's like they have a
connection and you can see the symbolism
of its rarity he lives outside a town
alone but his dead sister deb has
replaced his dead adoptive father harry
as that voice that he talks to inside of
his head it's that thing that acts as
his conscience that as viewers we see as
a manifestation the role she plays for
him doesn't seem to be the same as
harry's who acted as a guide in relation
to the code deb seems more like a
partner or support system in this period
of time where he's trying not to kill
anyone on the way into town we meet his
girlfriend angela who pulls him over in
a role-playing kind of situation that
gets hot until it gets interrupted
there's a call about runaway sheep
eating a neighbor's winter plantings and
there's no other officers available so
they have to take a rain check as he
walks through town we get the idea that
jim is well known and seems to be liked
by everyone he encounters and we also
find out through ramon as a helicopter
flies overhead that outsiders come to
the town at this time of year he's still
the donut guy at work or at least the
sweet roll guy and he's still
switzerland when it comes to weighing in
on disputes and again it seems like he
has a good rapport with his boss a
character named matt caldwell comes into
the store to purchase a knife and gun he
wants something impressive looking
that'll out do what his friend bill is
hunting with and he's unambiguously
unlikable all around he's loud entitled
he claims his dad is someone important
in town and he's got a high paying job
in finance which all adds up to him
carrying himself as if he owns the place
and all of that together seems to be
particularly grating for dexter as
matt's trying to convince him to
overlook the background check and just
let him have this gun dex plays by the
book he doesn't give in and because
there's no secrets in iron lake the
story of the background check comes up
as soon as he walks into the police
station to see angela the woman who was
working dispatch esther asked him about
it and offers up that she thinks it's
probably related to the boat accident
that happened back in ohio apparently
five people died and you can see
dexter's radar going off when he hears
this deputy logan stands up for matt
saying that he's a good guy that he
wasn't even driving and that he was in
the hospital for weeks he's sure it was
only a really tragic accident and goes
so far as to say that he bets matt's
record would be spotless until he looks
and sees that okay there are a few spots
and again you can see that dexter's
getting noticeably uncomfortable and
eventually changes the subject
in her office angela has a board filled
with missing young girls and she just
came out of a meeting where she tells
dex that there's no bodies no pattern
and there's no funding until one of them
turns up dead so it looks like these
girls have been going missing for some
time but there's no evidence that they
were killed or what happened to them
that night dexter and angela go line
dancing it seems like that's what
everyone in town does and we get a
little more acquainted with the people
and we get a little bit more from matt
as he tries to get the rifle again and
he invites dexter to a party there's a
cut to a different scene where we see a
rig pulling up to a caldwell truck stop
that's about two miles away from iron
lake and we see a mysterious figure get
out then as dexter's leaving the tavern
we see that same person watching him and
again during his morning routine the
next morning the person's there makes a
noise and scares the deer away so he's
starting to feel like someone's watching
him and he's right there's a protest
outside the tavern because the oil
billionaire is inside and using it for
his board meeting which is a problem for
dexter who can't enjoy his tuna fish
salad for lunch angela's daughter's
there and she catches his attention
whenever she dumps out this cup of cocoa
that he gave the crowd and it earns her
a stern look from the billionaire it's
one of those shots where the camera
lingers so you can't miss it the
background check finally goes through
and fred jr tells dexter to deliver the
gun to him he goes inside there's a
party raging bill takes him upstairs
they find out that matt's busy he's
having sex with the young woman and
while they're waiting bill tells him he
needs a straightener and goes in the
bathroom to start snorting lines he
brought the girl to the party so he's
distraught and as he's getting high he
starts to open up to dexter eventually
and somewhat out of the blue he
confesses that he covered for matt on
the boat that matt's father paid him to
lie at the trial and when dexter pushes
a little he finds out that they were
playing chicken and that the other guy
actually yielded he gave up but matt
crashed into him anyway because he
didn't like him and this is exactly the
kind of thing dex needs to fit him into
his code as he's handing the gun off we
see that he's really starting to think
about this when he has a vision of
smashing him in the face but ultimately
leaves without incident when he arrives
back at his cabin he sees a light turn
on inside and he grabs a hatchet before
sneaking in the side door inside he
finds his son harrison who's now grown
looking through his desk he asks him
point blank if he's dexter morgan and
before he can answer deb appears to him
warning him not to tell the truth you
can't everyone close to you dies that's
why we're here and he does decide to lie
it's difficult but deb persists to the
point of pulling a bullet out of her
stomach to make the point he doubles
down even though harrison knows he's his
father and just offers him some money
for the bus out of town the next night
promising that he won't say anything
about him breaking into the cabin after
he goes he finds a picture of them
together and he watches him walk away
through the window deb tells him he did
the right thing and that harrison will
be safer with hannah and then we see
dexter burn the photo and the fire
outside he has a nightmare where he sees
deb on his ice fishing line where he's
reeling it in and she's grabbed by a
dark figure and pulled under the water
when he wakes up she tells him that
she's glad that she went first and that
she loves him for making it 10 years
without a kill the next morning while
he's stalking the deer he's able to
approach it and just as he's reaching
his hand out and having a moment with
the animal a shot rings out and it goes
down matt runs up because of course he
shot it and this time jim follows
through with the idea of knocking him
out with the butt of his rifle and
probably the best sequence of the entire
episode he makes the decision to kill
matt and the voice over internal
dialogue comes back saying it's been a
long time he puts the deer out of its
misery and then prepares a makeshift
kill room for matt he notices there's
some blood coming from the back of his
head and says out loud sorry about the
mess i'm out of practice he puts
together a couple pieces of broken glass
as a blood slide and in the process matt
wakes up aside from the impromptu
feeling of the kill room dex quickly
falls back into his old routine he wants
matt to tell him what he did he wants
him to own it and when he says or
there's a funny call back to him waving
the knife around inside the fishing game
store after a back and forth he gets him
to cop to it and then matt shifts to
trying to blame it all on bad parenting
as he begs for his life this makes him
think about his own childhood and how he
wouldn't have had any direction if it
wasn't for harry and in that moment the
seeds are planted for him to go after
harrison he tells matt that they passed
the point of no return and things shift
where matt tries to threaten him he says
my dad knows everyone in this town and
he will find you and rain down a world
of pain which is enough for dex to move
on to silencing him we hear him say
tonight's the night hello dexter morgan
it feels just like old times but then he
gets a phone call from angela they were
supposed to get together so he lies
about why he can't make it and then when
he gets off the phone he says he doesn't
need trophies anymore and that he may be
a monster but he's an evolving monster
and then he moves on to dismembering the
body
then we see him head to his truck deb
pops up to ask him what he's doing and
he says not listening to you and in the
voice over we hear him talking about how
his life has always been truth adjacent
but starting now there will be one less
lie he goes to the bus station and gives
harrison a winter jacket before telling
him that he was right i'm dexter morgan
your father and he asked him to come
home as he's bringing him back to the
cabin we hear him think about how he's
going to take care of his son the same
way harry took care of him and we get
the sense that he's worried that if
there's no one there for harrison he may
turn out just like dexter as they go
inside we notice that there's blood on
the snow outside the cabin there's a
trail of it it's probably from that
wound in the back of matt's head and the
episode ends there with the familiar
blood theme playing over the closing
credits
so yeah i thought it was a pretty solid
start the deer was an interesting end to
show who he is now the stalking without
a kill at the end the rarity of it being
albino and his assumed connection to
that it all makes you wonder how long it
took for that to become part of his
everyday routine overall i'm buying his
lifestyle it mostly seems like a good
fit for the version of dexter who's
trying not to indulge his dark passenger
it doesn't seem off for him to live this
kind of life although even before matt
was dropped in his lap it looked like
there was doubt that he could keep it up
i really liked how they stress that it's
a small community where there are no
secrets except the glaring one that we
know about just that prolific serial
killer that never got caught hanging out
and going line dancing with the chief of
police i thought the way that they held
off on it and then reintroduced the
voice over waiting that far into the
episode was really effective it felt
like something was missing and it made
it all the more meaningful when it
kicked in deb had a great introduction
even though we knew she was coming it
was still a great surprise and it did
appear that she was an effective coping
mechanism right up to the point where he
killed again given that this is his
conscience it's not really dead but it
does distinctly have her personality
it'll be really fun to watch that
internal struggle as he tries not to
continue killing especially now that
harrison is in the picture the sex scene
between angela and dex was pretty
effective for developing their
relationship it makes it seem like
they've been together for a while but
they're keeping things exciting it also
works to show that they make time for
each other since it seems like they made
the decision to have them not sleep at
each other's places she's got a daughter
and they need to have him off alone so
they can maximize the dead scenes the
whole matt situation was convenient and
predictable for me it was the least
exciting part of it but the end result
of jim going full dexter is what's
really important i guess you can make a
safe assumption that his father will be
throwing resources at trying to find him
now that he's missing and he seems to
have sway on everyone in town according
to the character description plus we saw
his name on the truck stop which means
that he is definitely a public figure
obviously there's something big brewing
with the missing girls that would hint
that there's someone who's going to be
more interesting to dexter than matt was
there's also some little details here
that might come up again later the
stolen pies that logan recovered the
protest and that look from ed olsen and
of course the girl that angela helped
out at the bar i think it did what it
needed to do it set things up and i'm
interested to see where things go from
here really curious to find out how
harrison ended up there in the first
place and how dexter is going to explain
the whole faking his death thing and
that seems like a pretty good place to
leave things let me know in the comments
what you thought of the first episode
where you think things are going what
are you hoping to see please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon